[Music]
most beautiful in make news oh you have
another one huh is it going to be a
light-skinned man no it's going to be a
beautiful lady of some sort you know
he's a like a model because I looked at
his Instagram and I was like damn I
remember this guy he got a mug shot and
now he's famous for real he's a model
now he's a model he's a good looking
mother [ __ ] that one got away
well I hope you perform now after this
whole pretty probably made some money
Fashion Week and [ __ ] like how this is
our society but cash me outside girl
becomes a millionaire this guy does a
crime it goes viral Kim Kardashian dr.
jiggle I'm a crime for this comedy
YouTube [ __ ] I didn't [ __ ] get us
except with them I'm not you get to
[ __ ] Brent for living while wearing T
Rex Hays push-ups
yep I'm not as successful if there's no
stuff more than honorable you know I
jokingly that we're cool but they're
even more successful for doing nothing
right changed my life that's not how
about it you're happier now are you sure
about that
freaking crew it's not about me what's
going on
submitted by a game of Jose I would
watch that show
that's drug dealers muggers and thieves
have battled it out to be crowd the most
beautiful idiot to have a pageant
because this is a Philippines that your
guess what else you guys guessed right
Brazil Spain Brazil Russia Philippine
resolves a good guess do is right with
Russia Oh everyone know have you seen
the Russian women they're like being
honest what makes you think it's girl
you should also read that it throws off
you can see I thought it was going to be
a guys beauty pageant guys are the only
ones in our inmates I know but then it's
just something different that the guys
could do that isn't so macho
oh you know they like to subject women
in other countries more so than in the
US by that's why I kind of put all that
they're shameless about it too yeah you
think it's really about rejecting women
or women they're enjoy being women well
they've been subjected for so for so
long that they think that's all they're
good for if I was a
girl and I had a day to feel like a
beautiful woman and not an inmate I
would take that chance
let's imagine you ain't fresh you all
raggedy in a jumpsuit hair all [ __ ] up
but you get a day where you can feel
like a beautiful princess and be a woman
not shackled and chained
yeah but I just don't see it as regular
prison behavior and I don't really see
like the inmate I mean the guards and
that putting forth so much mental effort
and physical effort til I put this
together for anything if a girl's pretty
I'll let her out of prison I'll tell you
this though too
when the girl done does herself her mood
is [ __ ] on for yup she feels good
like you not really I see some really
happy ugly people that are [ __ ] dirty
damn well I'm not dirty they're like a
happy little Bulldog that lives outside
are they gonna shoot this prison
calendar with these hot female are they
pretty hot I will be love to you I'd
subjected their buddies and I agree with
you Russian women are beauty mm-hmm I
know this is the third annual survey oh
wow beauty pageant that was held at this
all-female penal colony number seven
Jail yes located in Russia and so this
woman who are serving 13 years behind
bars for dealing drugs oh she's just
delicious enough princess crown the
winner but she's just a businesswoman so
she's Miss P no way number solution yes
June this spring miss spring 3 sorry
name is uh Ivanka Irina did you come out
and like a bikini that's orange color
looks like the jumpsuit returns around a
lot of each other small bikini two eyes
that I noticed that too
it's your bikini on your nipples bro
yeah I know and then there's like a tiny
font in main number what the [ __ ] you
don't recall those micro kinis yeah yeah
why do you know that baby I know a lot
of things about women huh
that's what you think I was already sure
you get your period
okay in a beauty supply store I talk to
a lot of women and you were you would
think up with them I get it I know we'll
give such bad news to Gerald I actually
seen Bart's invention of a girl's shirt
with just a booby Parker out I've seen
it somewhere mean girl girl yeah yeah I
don't know that movie so eight drug
dealers muggers and thieves participated
and that sounds like the beginning of
the show with the pictures already know
I want to keep telling you because if I
show you pictures I lose your attention
I don't like how we're calling these
women I'm working their way here you go
you gaze at the man oh hi Rena I can't
even see her face she got some [ __ ] up
teeth but good job Betty what is it a
[ __ ] prison
yeah so the guards were the judges where
did they get the funding to buy all
these horrible you know the same thing
what if they made it on their own
yeah we're waiting on much clothes
welcome to went into a time machine
what why do they look like they're in
1972 yeah I don't know who this guy is
or why he's there is not the time yeah
so the theme was amazing all the keys to
like to be about nature who made the
outfit what maybe the maybe other
inmates my costume this is awesome there
was for just the West Boy George yeah so
there were four portions of his beauty
pageant so the first one they had to do
a catwalk state those faces I just
watched on the whole thing just looks
like a makeup that this looking they're
saying that for round two they had to
take part in a dance-off I would have
won that one so they just get on the
phone and kick your legs out in round
three like that does they has to do
their best impressions of famous Russian
celebrities yeah well that's why that's
política is he right hand oh I know I
don't know I don't know Joyce applauded
agofsky and then for the fourth and
final round the inmates had to walk down
the runway in the special costumes that
for this year represented ecology
where's the micro kini portion there is
none
it is pretty cool it's awesome I know it
is reported that they made their own
costumes but it isn't reported like how
they change that means our Miss
America's and all that stuff is a little
[ __ ] dirty compared to this this
they're so conservative
hey all right pop beauty fashion I
thought a bikini portion girls like
[ __ ] is this so horny it brings up
their morale and they bring everyone
together there's so much more productive
yeah also spent two months prepping for
this let's go yeah what a cool [ __ ]
idea
we got 101 roses a crown and a set of
makeup what if they get out of the jail
and they're like man real life is [ __ ]
boring I want to be back and be a [ __ ]
pageant queen again so they go shoot
someone [ __ ] yeah I'm best at the queen
is back so Irena will be eligible for
release in 2000 good ol Joe seems way
cooler than guy Jail like I watch orange
is the new black and hands down if I
commit a crime I would much rather be in
girl jail of course if you're a guy we
all rather be in girl jail not me like
going is metered yeah like it's cool no
you know like I don't know maybe there's
politics and stuff but like I feel like
I could survive in girl jail guy jail oh
no I know I can survive in either or I
would somehow voice it being a [ __ ]
bottom [ __ ] same I like being outside
in the free world same I don't even want
to think of that thought my crime in and
of itself if you get those high emotions
you just really think about having all
your human rights stripped away that is
a frightening frightening thing for me
like if I knew there's a hey you're
going to be in jail for the next like
ten years
I just [ __ ] kill me you're a robot I
think I could write a really good movie
if I went to jail because then like I
don't have anything to do so that's all
I got to focus on I get fed I have a
place to sleep I'm gonna care about
bills
none of that responsibility it's like
being a kid again but if you got life I
could write a really good movie and when
bar comes to visit I could hand them the
script and we can make that [ __ ] happen
and we can have a screening at the jail
with me my jail buddies
yourself of you had 10 years I think the
the 10 year you would kill yourself with
10 years you only do a quarter of your
time dude oh I think I'm about full I
think about full time I have to be there
for 10 years
okay he got 20 years he does 10 years
well how old are you now would you guys
be done if they had like I know they
have like Navy SEAL for a day
you know those events which would be
down to do like a jail for like a day or
jail yeah is there any I'd be down a you
know intrusion no okay
just the schedule collecting even a
schedule is hard like sometimes you know
like I think every day was up at the
same time
everyone's jail cells open right yeah
yeah file out and then at night it's
like lights out at 10:00 or something so
everyone goes you have to sleep so yup
the sleep on command wake up on command
do all those things you have to [ __ ]
while looking at your neighbor like all
those things is it a schedule is it just
a life in a schedule or also the threat
life life and the schedule so like I
could do that everyone taking a shower
for 30 seconds at the same time everyone
in peanut butter jelly sandwich at the
same time but the fact that I will be
able to go back out in society I'm very
willing to do it it's just like for me
even being cooped up in my own house
gives me anxiety so if I'm put into a
system or I can't even see daylight for
most of the time except for maybe a
couple of hours of the day I would
probably rip out my own [ __ ] hair
like the concept of freedom to me is
very very very important more than money
more than anything else in this world to
be able to wake up and do what I like is
something that I value a lot like to the
pump degree that's true you know because
it's all like alright you come out now
you go back in your cell I just stay
there for 12 hours it's just for white
walls
that's the torment probably I probably
would rather just be in solitary to
myself there's no music no anything no
entertainment no TV that torture is
worse I'll just think to myself all day
yeah no not yeah what God knows I will
go all over that's pretty crazy actually
never thought about that yeah I will go
insane I think like mentally I would
snap so what do they get into arts and
crafts in yeah and they make dorito bag
frames or if they allow me to I guess
like in the present if they allow me to
enrich myself where I can do art but
check out a book read books you know
what I mean or even take classes I would
even do that where somebody is giving me
a lecture
would rather do that then just be a
[ __ ] prison base where I just rot
away can't do it life and time is very
important to me thanks for watching just
kidding news guys don't forget to
comment down below we want to hear what
you say only if it's positive remember
that to watch more videos go up here
baby
[Music]